[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisiones de
reporteros de france 24 comenzamos costa
de márfil tendrá elecciones
presidenciales el 31 de octubre el
actual presidente álex and white hará de
78 años está entre los cuatro candidatos
y se postula para un controvertido
tercer mandato en un contexto tenso una
parte de la sociedad civil lo señala de
traicionar el espíritu de la
constitución y enfrenta a una oposición
que le ha pedido al pueblo desobediencia
civil en este país durante los últimos
25 años los comicios han sido escenario
de violencia post-electoral
frecuentemente con numerosas víctimas
fatales en esta edición de reporteros
les contamos lo que está en juego para
este país que busca una reconciliación
duradera y las preocupaciones que crecen
por la seguridad nacional incluso la onu
ha pedido a todas las partes que
entierren sus diferencias nos acompaña a
carolina jaume ella es una de las
autoras de este reportaje tu gusto es la
oportunidad de estar con los marfileños
antes de estas elecciones con que se
encontró
y es absurdo si fuimos del stec yo fue
hasta el sur de grand bassam como en
uruguay que fue lo que encontramos a
pesar de que fue muy pacífico debo decir
que todo fue muy pacífico la gente está
preocupada es decir hay una especie de
ansiedad hacia las elecciones no por el
voto ya sabes en costa de marfil han
estado votando desde los años 60
incluso desde los 90 con elecciones de
múltiples partidos para ti sino que esta
vez es un poco especial porque los
candidatos los hombres son los mismos
que estuvieran durante la crisis durante
la guerra así que la gente está un poco
preocupada de que el conflicto pueda
comenzar de nuevo pero son pacíficos y
tienen esperanza dónde a hopeful
invitados entonces a ver el siguiente
reportaje
[Música]
en el oeste de costa de marfil las
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
reviven los recuerdos de las masacres
perpetradas durante la crisis
poselectoral de 2011 se colocó una
estela sobre una fosa común todos aquí
han perdido un padre un hermano o un
primo no hubo ninguna investigación
según se informa los combates entre los
rebeldes del norte que apoyaban a
alassane ouattara y la población local a
favor del ejército del presidente bajo
provocaron más de mil muertes hoy en día
los jóvenes que viven en el barrio
mártir de carrefour se niegan a ir a las
urnas
tal vez pueda suceder en el resto de
duekué no lo sabemos pero nosotros aquí
ni siquiera necesitamos un colegio
electoral para participar en la vida
electoral de costa de marfil morimos de
forma gratuita ganaron estamos cansados
no queremos más déjenlos en paz
serie perdió 38 miembros de su familia
en los combates de 2011 hay un hombre
siguiendo la conversación no es oriundo
de esta región pero vivendi fue desde
hace casi 20 años ya di paso por todas
las crisis de esta ciudad
ahora tiene una pequeña tienda en el
centro
como mi tienda fue saqueada
completamente saqueada tanto así que
hasta arrancaron las lámparas lo perdí
todo realmente las crisis me costaron
mucho dinero y nunca nunca nunca
recibiremos ayuda
para evitar esos peligros xavi invirtió
en plantaciones la tierra extremadamente
fértil es objeto de toda codicia
causando conflictos de tierras en un
país donde es muy difícil confirmar
cualquier título de propiedad
chad y tiene tres hectáreas de anacardos
6 hectáreas de cacao y 18 hectáreas de
árboles de caucho suena como si fuera
mucho pero sus rendimientos son muy
bajos además los precios mundiales se
derrumbaron gana 150 euros netos por una
tonelada de caucho los agricultores
esperan que el futuro gobierno imponga
un mejor precio de compra pero señalan
que la cuestión agrícola no es una
prioridad en la campaña electoral
y ya pasó
mientras que un lado no quiere organizar
elecciones el otro lado si quiere que
ocurran así que el tema que están
debatiendo no es la agenda del gobierno
no es lo que cada uno puede hacer por
los campesinos sino cómo organizar las
elecciones cómo hacerlas ese es el tema
así que nosotros estamos a la
expectativa
esta región produce una parte importante
del cacao del que costa de marfil es el
primer productor mundial
pero desafortunadamente los que producen
cacao no conocen el chocolate y su cola
y el campesino puede morir sin haber
probado nunca el chocolate y su culo
es triste no se habla mucho de ingresos
agrícolas o de industrias de
procesamiento de nuestra elección pero
se habla mucho de los trabajadores
inmigrantes familias de burkina faso se
han asentado en la aldea de hacen estás
dos plantaciones ellos también esperan
ansiosamente esta votación
las elecciones tienen que ser limpias
tienen que llegar a un acuerdo a hacer
las paces la persona que va a ser
presidente tiene que cuidarnos bien eso
es todo
recorrimos un largo camino para vivir en
este país solo tiene que entenderse para
que los que están en burkina ghana mali
senegal vengan en mayor cantidad a su
país
ah
en costa de marfil los enfrentamientos
entre comunidades suelen comenzar con
conflictos de tierras con poblaciones de
los países vecinos pero no siempre en la
ciudad debe um y las elecciones locales
de 2018 también habían dado lugar a la
violencia
un imán se había distinguido entonces
por sus esfuerzos de mediación vamo
keita es uno de los imanes más jóvenes
del país hijo de um y es parte de la
generación que creció con el desarrollo
del islam en un país que una vez fue
predominantemente cristiano en mayo de
2019 un altercado entre los baúles y
viola se convirtió en un enfrentamiento
entre comunidades con un saldo de 17
muertos frente a la alcaldía debe um y
se erigió un monumento en homenaje a las
víctimas y hoy en día los dirigentes
locales siguen hablando de ello
porque hubo muchas reuniones reyes jefes
de altea jefes de cantón jefes de
comunidad efe es tradicional jefes
religiosos jefes de cantones imanes y
sus colaboradores todos estaban de
acuerdo en esto tratamos de intercambiar
durante un mes dos meses realmente
hablamos decimos porque tanto bla bla
bla porque ya no queremos eso en bv
realmente intercambiamos creo que ese
día el rey porque tomó un palo y vino a
dárselo animal nos dijo si le damos esto
es para decir que ya no hacemos
palabrería el palo está con el imán
dijimos que de verdad de verdad lo que
hizo está bien que los políticos
necesitan cambiar su lenguaje realmente
es muy importante para la gente de de um
y tanto para los nobles como para los
jjoo la necesitas saber que estamos
juntos necesitas saber que seamos julie
malling que hable somos lo mismo somos
todos los mismos marfileños la bandera
que está en blooming naranja blanco
verde es la misma bandera y está en
korhogo
son las ciudades como ve um y donde hay
tanto baile como dhul a las que tienen
más probabilidades de salirse de control
los funcionarios están haciendo todo lo
posible para evitar las manifestaciones
electorales y el imán sigue haciendo
todo lo posible y son los jóvenes baúles
los que están aquí se las arreglan con
la carpintería así que este es mi lugar
ese es el imán vivimos juntos no hay
palabrería es mi vecino este joven baile
cómo te llamas inglés les viste estamos
aquí juntos y aquí están los jóvenes de
libras
este es el jefe cómo va todo también
está cosiendo esto es lo que pone el pan
en la mesa en lugar de la pelea
[Música]
el imán vamos keita pide que las
elecciones sean pacíficas pero también
que las condiciones de vida en veo me
mejoren estamos en problemas
no tenemos pavimento no tenemos energía
el pueblo no está muy iluminado
necesitamos energía pero ni veo me han
recibió pavimento pero me necesita 18 20
kilómetros así todo lo que se pueda
desarrollar de um y lo necesita
[Música]
la gente del norte está pidiendo la
misma infraestructura que en el sur en
efecto cuanto más vaya uno al sur más
pavimentados estarán los caminos en
yamusukro algunas carreteras fueron
arregladas por la cercanía de las nuevas
elecciones
ese mundo hicimos de oslo
soy el comandante retirado simon pierre
estoy retirado desde el 31 de diciembre
trabajo aquí en fondue en la
subprefectura de yamusukro allí estoy
haciendo mi pequeña casa de retiro es
difícil cada periodo preelectoral es un
momento de incertidumbre esperamos que
las cosas vayan bien para que podamos
llevar a cabo los proyectos de cada uno
los pequeños proyectos de cada uno
cuando los discursos son la oposición
radical el poder rígido da un poco de
miedo
para relajarse el comandante a menudo va
a la casa de un amigo en las orillas de
bandama un exmilitar que como él
aprovechó su bono de jubilación para
montar su propio restaurante
los militares que lucharon entre ellos
durante la guerra también deben aprender
a vivir juntos
el ejército está dividido cuando el
ejército se unificó todos los hermanos
de armas nos perdonamos jesús porque los
militares siguen siendo militares es
manipulación política
están usando al ejército para dividirlo
hay que perdonarlo todo es inútil si
tenemos que ir de venganza en venganza
nunca vamos a salir de ellos
el perdón es una palabra recurrente en
costa de márfil se están organizando
oraciones en todas las iglesias del país
para que las elecciones tengan lugar en
un clima apaciguado en esta iglesia
metodista de yamusukro incluso se están
recaudando fondos para organizar una
caravana de paz
la gente manipula a los crédulos
diciendo que hay una oposición sur-norte
o cristianos contra musulmanes vivimos
en buenos términos son aseveraciones
falsas el presidente de la república no
es cristiano el poder viene de dios
rezamos rezamos por el presidente
desde yamusukro la capital política
hasta abiyán la capital económica el
camino es bueno y si se quiere ir más
lejos hay una nueva autopista que
incluso lleva a grand bassam justo antes
de llegar a la antigua capital una zona
franca es la de vitis la aldea de la
biotecnología y las tecnologías de la
información y la comunicación
fátima está se instaló allí en 2015 y
construyó sus estudios de televisión el
concepto de la zona franca propició su
desarrollo
estamos exentos de aranceles e iba así
que es un gran alivio para nosotros
porque el material audiovisual es muy
caro para hacer un espectáculo cuesta
mucho dinero y estamos renovando los
equipos siempre hay algo nuevo siempre
estamos en lo a la fama
desde las empresas audiovisuales hasta
las industrias farmacéuticas cada vez
más empresas se instalan en esta zona de
casi 200 hectáreas la zona franca tardó
varios años en despegar pero los
candidatos de hoy están luchando por
participar en ella
en la sede de vitti pascal pango que
defendió este proyecto desde el
principio sigue soñando
nosotros también podemos soñar con tener
nuestro parque tecnológico nuestro
centro en su región de áfrica occidental
tenemos derecho a nuestra silicon valley
no veo porque no tendríamos ese tipo de
sueño estima que dentro de 10 años más
de 40 mil personas podrían estar
trabajando en esta zona franca y para
aquí pasa hasta el otro lado y atraviesa
la laguna 4 kilómetros de cerca que
estamos construyendo mi opinión y la del
hombre de negocios nuestro papel aquí es
atraer a los inversores atraer grandes
proyectos obviamente estamos impactados
por las noticias políticas pero sigo
siendo optimista la comunidad
empresarial de costa de marfil quiere
que pasen rápidamente las elecciones la
media de tumor para ledesma el año
pasado todo el mundo hablaba del 2020 no
hacemos nada
esperamos que el 2020 se iba a poner
bueno finalmente en el 2020 que pasó que
no esperábamos
kobe de 19 de ver confiar en el hecho de
que hemos tenido una historia de guerra
y que siempre tendremos
eso no es cierto pero todos los
marfileños que vayan a votar pongamos al
presidente que queremos a la cabeza del
país y sigamos trabajando oportunidad
otra vez
[Música]
en costa de márfil todas las elecciones
celebradas desde 1995 fueron seguidas
por graves crisis post electorales los
marfileños esperan que este año sea una
excepción
el reportaje se centra en el de una
población al oeste del país que fue
duramente golpeada por la violencia
postelectoral de 2011 y nadie sabe cómo
reaccionar a esta vez qué piensan sus
habitantes carolyn
y realmente no sabemos por qué yo que es
un lugar muy singular ellos pagaron un
precio muy alto durante la guerra y
nadie sabe realmente cómo van a
reaccionar en fin ese debut no consigues
yo que no hubo reconciliación no hubo
investigación de crímenes de guerra no
hubo justicia ni tampoco hubo
compensación para las víctimas solo
compensation fue victims shop y por
entonces la gente tiene derecho de estar
molesta prácticas speak to the wall pero
cuando hablas con ellos básicamente
dicen que no van a votar dicen que van a
crear una especie de boicot pero no
necesariamente van a crear conflicto
ellos no quieren más guerra ya han
perdido muchas personas sólo escuchen al
líder de la comunidad guerra
way quien es también un miembro de la
cámara nacional de los reyes y líderes
tradicionales en yamusukro yo tenía
mucho q
no hemos pasado la página pero no creo
que estemos listos para entrar en otro
conflicto más que agua porque vimos a
muchos padres desaparecer y queriendo
empezar de nuevo
es como si nosotros mismos no
quisiéramos existir porque si tienes las
manos desnudas y vas y atacas a gente
más armada que tú estás caminando hacia
la muerte al macbook
le provoca provocar cuando tienes una
cauchera y la otra persona tiene un arma
se posa con tal vez todo el mundo puede
cambiar y hacerlo pero nosotros
preferimos ser nosotros como prefiere
este número
y no copiamos ni nos dejamos arrastrar
por la gente porque la gente que
enfrenta las consecuencias somos
nosotros no ellos
una de las personas con la que usted
converso en el reportaje hablaba de la
necesidad de perdonar a todo el mundo es
esto posible
me hago la misma pregunta para el perdón
comprendes que la gente necesita saber y
entender 'no estándar tipo unit nuevo
honda y nicky ellos quieren perdonar y
quieren pasar página deben conocer la
verdad y no te cruz
si ves otros países como sudáfrica en
donde hubo una comisión de paz y
reconciliación para perdonar y
reconciliar ellos deberían tener la
verdad debieron sentarse todos juntos o
pensar y dar detalles de los crímenes de
guerra esto es algo que nunca ha pasado
en costa de marfil con inagra cost show
en chile wind donde es hasta que sepamos
qué pasó durante la guerra civil que
duró diez años no sabremos si la gente
esté dispuesta a perdonarte fockers
gracias carlin por acompañarnos en la
emisión de este reportaje a ustedes
también gracias por acompañarnos
recuerde que puede ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
plans 24 punto com hasta la próxima
semana
[Música]